I have a home that's about 24 years old
and it is in need of like Renovations as
far as it needs probably um the siding
removed and put new siding up or fiber
cement or something like that is what I
really want to do and also possibly put
um a little sun room on the back of the
house and we have no debt my husband and
I we drive very old cars um we don't eat
out a lot so we kind of want to do
something you know to the to the house
like that but I'm kind of scared as far
as I want to retire at
60 um but I don't know if I can swing
all this and without I don't know if I
have to get a HELOC or if I could use I
know you're not gonna pay off that house
and then borrow against it again right I
don't want to do that you're not gonna
do that don't even say it out loud yeah
it's not even an option you've been
listening to this show you knew not to
say that here